les lendemains éprouvants de la
libération.
STEEVE NÉRON,
Canadien vivant en Ukraine
- Bonjour Tamara. Écoute,
je suis le long du boulevard
Beryslav...
- Ça fait neuf mois que nous
communiquons régulièrement
avec Steeve Néron, mais
c'est la première fois
que nous pnsnsns le nommer
et le montrer à la caméra.
- On est 13 h 30 à peu près, là.
- Cet après-midi, il se balade
à pied dans son quartier
à la recherche de quelques
produits frais.
- You can say hello to Canada
if you want.
(rires)
- Le Canadien vit à Kherson
en Ukraine. Il aura survécu
au siège de l'armée russe depuis
le tout début de la guerre,
presque toujours confiné à
la maison.
- J'ai un sous-sol qui n'est pas
apparent..
- Depuis sa résidence, une
des plus cossues du quartier,
il nous montre où il s'est caché
chaque fois que les Russes
frappaient à la porte.
- En mettant un tapis et
une plante, ni vu ni connu.
Les Russes ne peuvaient pas
savoir.
- Des mois à se morfondre avec
sa femme et ses beaux-parents,
des Ukrainiens, en attendant
la libération de Kherson
le 12 novembre.(c(c(cris de joi)
- Il y a eu l'euphorie des trois
premières journées, que les gens
étaient dans la rue, tout le
monde souriait, tout lndndnde...
c'était les accolades...
(soupir)
... tellemcococontents que
les forces russes soient
parties, mais dorénavant,
c'est totalement changé.
- Ils sont libres, mais comme
tous les résidents de Kherson
et de sa banlieue, il paie
le prix de la défaite et
de l'humiliation des Russes.
- Il n'y a plus d'électricité,
il n'y a plus d'eau dans
la ville. euh...
(déflagration au loin)
- Et il y a des bombardements...
(déflagration)
... du matin au soir. Les rues
sont désertes. Ce n'est que sur
la grand-place du centre-ville
que les gens circulant en masse
poe e e brancher au reste
du monde.
- Pour être capable de recharger
la batterie des téléphones.
- C'est aussi la course
pour trouver de l'eau.
- À l'arrière, vous pouvez
voir mon bassin, ma piscine.
Depuis ce matin, au moins
une dizaine de personnes
sont venues chercher de l'eau
pour être capable de vidanger
leur toilette.
- Mais les jours sont comptés
avant le grand froid de l'hiver.
Des milliers de résidences
se sont donc résignés et ont
commencé à évacuer d'urgence.
Ils ont pris d'assaut
les stations d'essence,
qui peinent à fournir, et
les autobus qui donnent priorité
aux femmes et aux enfants.
Les Russes sont justes
de l'autre côté du Dniepr
et continuent de cibler
et de démolir toute
l'infrastructure essentielle
à l'approche de l'hiver.
- C'est impossible pour
les gens de pouvoir survivredan.
(déflagration au loin)
Ça va ressembler à Donetsk...
On vient d'entendre encore
un tir d'artillerie.
- Il manque aussi cruellement
de médecins et de médicaments
explique Steeve, dont la femme
travaille dans une clinique
de santé avec le strict minimum.
- Ma femme avait une équipe
de huit, et déjà, dans
d d dernière semaine,
cinq sont partis. Ils ne sont
plus que trois dans son équipe.
(déflagration au loin)
Donc, les deux autres, d'asss
moi après quelques semaines
de bombardements, vont venir
à l'évidence qu'on ne peut pas
rester.
- Steeve veut partir lui aussi
et l'armée ukrainienne l'a
d'ailleurs prévenu.- Que mon see
chances de ne pas être détruit.
- Il se donncococore quelques
jours pour faire ses bagages et
surtout de convaincre sa famille
que, oui, ils sont libres,
mais pas invincibles.
Ici Tamara Alteresco,
Radio-Canada, Montréa